have some challenges with our cat and we
are and uh certainly you know
with dak and amari that's gonna shrink
it in a hurry
and uh you know we're gonna have
challenges but uh you know they're not
challenges that we can't overcome
so uh
you know it's gonna be something that
we've really gotta you know keep our
fingers on certainly if there's a cba if
there's not a cba
if there's not a cda things get a lot
tighter
in terms of the rules so you know we'll
have to deal with that just think about
going another direction at the position
absolutely not i mean that's our
quarterback and uh you know he's our
quarterback for the future and we have
nothing but the greatest respect for him
he's a competitor
uh you know he's won a lot of football
games for us so obviously he like us we
all want to take that next step
stephen jones cowboys co making it clear
that they have not considered going in a
different direction from that very clear
right that's the closest he can say
anything relevant or related in any way
to tom brady you know that's one of the
challenges this week and we need to do
the remedial tampering training with you
there have been times in the past where
you have just blurted out guys under
contract with other teams here talking
to coaches
but you can't you can't
comment on tom brady or any other
quarterback that's still under contract
with another team and they're all still
under contract any guys who are going to
be free agents next month still under
contracts with the current team but dak
prescott technically under contract with
the cowboys they want to get him signed
stephen jones said yesterday that there
have been no discussions between the
team and prescott's agent todd francis i
was shocked amber i was shocked when i
heard that but there's nothing to talk
about yeah the thing what's there to
talk about once the season is going and
you've exchanged your offers and that's
it you're just playing out the final
year of the conference well i just
thought like once we got to eight and
eight and we're not making the playoffs
that i would hear there'd be some a few
moments of dialogue ballpark numbers
what we're thinking when we'll get back
to you here something like that deadline
driven business once you get see there's
value before the season starts in
negotiating with dak prescott because if
you do a deal with him then you take
away from him the injury risk that comes
from playing out the contract that's the
reason to do it right after the season
ends
there's no reason for him to talk the
next deadline is the application of the
franchise tag that and i was talking
about this earlier on radio there are
certain points that we need to look at
application of the franchise tag
deadline that's the next
key deadline for prescott because the
cowboys want to get the deal done so
they can then use the tag on amari
cooper sure guy they gave a first round
pick to get from the raiders a year and
a half ago and he may walk away
and remember last year they were oh we
don't hey during uh the time period our
first round picks on the clock we'll be
watching tomorrow cooper film that's our
first round pick not if he's gone after
one year it's not so that's the the key
deadline try to get it done before the
franchise tag window closes so you can
tag cooper after that then the deadline
becomes getting it done well then it
becomes the option what do they do when
that happens that's because he's not
going to show up yeah he hasn't said it
i guarantee you he's not going to show
up no he seems like he is driving a hard
bargain there's no doubt about it about
that whether the comments we've heard
the way
he acted and talked when i did my little
interview with him down at the the super
bowl you know you could tell that there
was an unwavering confidence in him
right now to where he knows he's got the
cowboys by you know the kahunas a little
bit he's he's fully within his rights to
not show up right remember the cowboys
are the ones that are taking advantage
of the rules that allow them to keep him
off the open market with the franchise
tag once that happens he has rights
right and his rights include i'm not
showing up for anything until i sign a
contract have you mike florio who knows
a lot of people in football and also has
a good gut and when i hear your gut
sometimes i always think somebody's told
them something but either way have you
heard anything as far as numbers where
the hiccup is anything between those two
that way because i haven't heard like i
haven't heard one peep about it like
whoa they're this far off on guaranteed
money or you're no it's what it's always
been
it's the cowboys think there is inherent
value in being the quarterback of the
caliber right so for that reason you
should take less we heard that from
emmitt smith last week you should take
less because you're going to make it
back in marketing dollars and you're the
quarterback of the cowboys when you're
done playing you're going to walk right
into a broadcast booth i mean look jason
whitton troy aikman tony roman no doubt
right it's an easy pathway into a
30-year career i wanted to take less not
just for me maybe just because i want to
see him do well and have good team
around him because i like him but i'm
not trying to tell anybody what to do
with their money something that that i
really
wonder about is what he would get on the
open market yeah business is business
it's an important contract for dak it's
an important contract for our
organization jack is the quarterback of
the dallas cowboys he's young and he's
going to get extended i'm excited about
the opportunity to work with dak i've
always been impressed with him are you a
40 million dollar quarterback you tell
me it happens when it happens what's
going to be better signing a new
contract or not having to answer
questions about getting a new contract
i'll probably sign him yeah
[Music]
dak prescott still on deck for that
contract and as we went to break the
question i was posing is what would he
get if he actually were on the open
market because it's driven by franchise
tag values now and 35 million dollars
this and 37 million that like if you put
him on the open market free and clear
for any team to sign him especially this
year with so many other quarterbacks
what do you think he would get i i think
he's gonna get a contract that's better
than russell wilson i do i think that's
where it is you know and again just say
he's better than russell wilson right
now no he's not and i don't mean that to
disrespect dak prescott he's certainly
one of the ten best at the line to get
him if he was available ooh that's a
good question would you guys john gruden
be at the front of the line uh i think
that would sir that would be one that
would seriously think about it i mean if
i'm the carolina panthers and you're
starting a new team that might be a team
i would think about as well and bring
him in there then you can use other
assets to improve the team around it you
know i think there would be a lot of
takers for dak prescott he's selfless
selfless he's a leader he has talent
he's tough he's everything you want from
that perspective of a franchise
quarterback and i just want to remind
everybody you don't need to be the best
player to be the highest paid of your
position i mean derek carr was the
highest paid player in the history of
football at one point all right and
that's not a disrespect to derek carr
but i don't know you think i'm right
there i think you're right and look it's
funny you say selfless when he's trying
to get paid but you're not being selfish
to get paid darren woodson former
cowboys said yesterday it's a slap in
the face chargers take less get what you
can while you can you have a limited
window go get
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports